l'environnement le réchauffement de la
planète se confie en 2004 arrive au 4e
rang des années les plus chaudes
derrière 1998 2003 et 2002 c'est ce
qu'annonce l'organisation météorologique
mondiale
julia delage cette année 15 ouragans se
sont abattues sur l'atlantique
six de plus que l'an dernier cyclone
typhon mais aussi inondations 2004 a
connu un nombre inhabituel d'événements
extrêmes selon les climatologues en
cause le réchauffement climatique qui en
effet octobre dernier a battu tous les
records jamais enregistrée l'année
arrive ainsi au 4e rang des années les
plus chaudes de l'histoire aujourd'hui
178 pays sont rassemblés à buenos aires
objectif mobiliser le monde entier il
est impératif que les sociétés se
prépare aux conséquences inévitables du
changement climatique
c'est le défi que tu avoues ministre
vous devez relever un défi bien
audacieux le réchauffement de la planète
semble inexorable au pôle nord la
banquise recul -13 % en vingt ans et les
écarts de température se creuse enfin la
tendance ne risque pas de s'inverser en
un siècle l'émission de gaz carbonique a
augmenté de 40%